yeah it's my birthday but it's also also
a workday so we get some I got an early
morning here folks and we're gonna make
some YouTube videos let's do it
okay guys so I just arrived at the
studio and I've got to make some
breakfast for the whole crew because we
are starving and we need a little energy
before we get going and obviously I'm an
adult I can make my own decisions when
it comes to breakfast and it's my
birthday so I could eat birthday cake if
I wanted to but I don't think I would
feel so great and also I'm not really
into the whole cheat meal mentality even
on my birthday so I like to keep a
little more balanced so we're gonna do a
birthday cake smoothie Bowl and it's
gonna be really awesome
[Music]
I feel a lot better now that I have a
little breakfast in me and so I'm gonna
be doing a little collaboration video
with my friend Nikki from Health Net
nutrition this morning so I'm just gonna
wait for her to get here and in the
meantime go pop my dress on get the set
ready to go and we're gonna start
shooting
[Music]
that was so much fun I just said goodbye
to Nikki so we've got lots more to do
this afternoon I'm gonna do some recipe
testing but first I need some lunch
especially I wanted to eat rice pudding
all day I need some protein to keep me
going so I've got some leftover salmon
and olive salad that I made yesterday
while I was recipe testing for my
cookbook and I'm really excited to dig
in
[Music]
okay awesome last email the day sent now
I gotta squeeze a quick little workout
in before we head off to the party okay
guys I'm going to the gym gotta do a
workout even on my birthday
and it's probably gonna be a really hard
workout so watch me get tortured
right did you see that pretty much no
mercy for the birthday girl and Here I
am
doing a little bit of post workout
cardio it's just another day for Abby
so I'm just gonna get myself ready to go
out tonight and I'm multitasking of
course because I've had a really busy
day and I brought my snack here I always
try to have a snack before I go I have a
pretty nurse that I don't end up
ravenous by the time I get to the
restaurant and want to eat all the foods
a lot at one time so this really does
take that job no crab nice combination
of them pistachios and almonds for my
face
okay now we're ready to party
awesome awesome awesome day what a
birthday honestly all my fair foods all
my favourite friends were with me I had
an awesome workday and I am exhausted
I'm too old for this apparently but I'm
just gonna go right to bed
so I hope you guys enjoyed my little
what I eat in a day on my birthday if
you did be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with some other
fun scenarios for what I eat in a day
and subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abbey's kitchen
good night
you